good afternoon my name is cynthia moss
and karen david invited me to
co-organize this special session
enhancing species diversity and
neuroscience research
and i want to offer special thanks to
karen and to the ninds
for their support of comparative
research in neuroscience
so with the advent of genetic tools
research has
largely focused on a small set of animal
species
and though there have been many
important advances
through the study of these animals it's
essential to focus on the questions
that drive neuroscience research and
choose the champion animal
that is the animal that is best suited
to answer
a particular question so today we'll
hear about research
that adopts this approach specifically
we'll learn about new
discoveries that come from studies of
diverse animal subjects
marmoset that
prairie bowl siamese fighting fish or
betta fish
shellless mollusks nudibranch and
octopus each of these species
offers key advantages to studying
particular problems
an approach articulated by nobel
laureate
alexander croak about 100 years ago
croaks stated for such a large number of
problems there will be some animal of
choice
or a few such animals on which it can be
most conveniently studied
and major discoveries in neuroscience
have emerged from research that takes
advantage
of species specializations and i'll just
mention two that are certainly familiar
to many in the audience
so by measuring changes in electrical
charges in the axon
hodgkin and huxley discovered how nerve
impulses are exchanged between
cells the work was made possible by
selection of a suitable species with a
giant axon
the squid
many of you are also familiar with the
elegant studies of learning and memory
carried out by condell and his group
and this work exploits advantages of the
behaviors and nervous system
of the sea slug eplesia
so the goal of this session today is to
inform the community
of the brain initiative support for the
diversity of species used in
neuroscience research
by leveraging advances in genetics and
neuroscience tools new species are being
explored and developed
for their utility in addressing
outstanding neurobiological questions
this symposium will showcase research
that features non-traditional species
and specifically you'll hear about some
of the questions neuroscientists are
asking and the animals which hold the
answers to these questions
after the research presentations we'll
have a discussion that focuses on the
challenges and opportunities in
expanding the diversity of species in
neuroscience research
this discussion will be moderated by zoe
donaldson
so let me briefly introduce today's
speakers
um first cory miller from university of
california san diego
who will be speaking on spatial and
social behaviors in marmosets
angela salas from the johns hopkins
university will then
talk about spatial tracking and social
behavior
in bats zoe donaldson from the
university of colorado
will present work on social bonding and
parenting behaviors
in prairie bowls andreas ben
mendeski from columbia university will
talk about work on fighting fish and
their aggression in beta fish
paul katz from umass amherst will
discuss
foraging sensory motor behaviors in
mollusks
and finally galeed palette from michigan
state university
will discuss grasping behavior in
octopus
so now let's turn to our first speaker
corey miller who will tell us about his
work on marmoset social cognition
okay so first i just wanted to thank
karen for um
organizing this uh symposium on
expanding species diversity and
neuroscience
um where really one of the primary
motivations is to showcase all of the
the less traditional animal models and
neuroscience
and and sort of uh expand on
why it's really important to motivate
your research questions
with the appropriate model species
because
every animal does all of these really
interesting things and one of the
traditions has been to
um simply uh squeeze any question into
the
into a small subset of animals and there
you can really learn a lot by expanding
on that
um and one of the things that's
important to say with all of these
uh diverse species is i like all the
speakers today
are very um uh find it very important to
hold the highest standards in animal
welfare in our research on all of the
kind of work that we do
is scrutinized at the federal state and
local level
and is upheld very high standards for
research
all of these are approved by our ayat
cook that which meets not just the
animal welfare considerations
um but also uh high levels of
reproducibility and rigor
in the research and one of the key
motivations for doing
animal research for any taxi including
the ones that are that are discussed
here um is because animal models have
played such a crucial role
in the um development of disease
treatments and interventions
and this has been the case in the past
and will continue to be for the future
um so the animal model that i work on
are common marmosets um so there's a
small
new world primate um they've been around
in biomedical research for quite a long
time including neuroscience
but about five or six years ago they
really started accelerating
um and their usage and part of the
reason for this initially was that they
had a particular amenability to the
modern molecular toolkit that's
available
um with imaging and viral vectors and
opto
chemogenetic approaches um and so this
sort of brought them onto the stage but
in addition to this one of the reasons
that they've expanded is that
um they're a small body monkey which
gives certain advantages for
um logistical considerations um but
they're also a primate and so they have
the entire shared architecture
primary brain which has certain
implications for better understanding
humans
one of the things that's really emerged
as a key part of
why we use marmosets is that because
they're small they're they're amenable
to a range
of neural and behavioral recording
preparations
for freely moving animals which allows
us to look at more naturalistic
behaviors
so traditionally like you can see here
um the way that people have generally
studied primates is and restrain
the context where the animals are
looking at screens
and performing some kind of task but
this is not necessarily fully
representative of what
primates do so if you look at the breath
of
really a species entire repertoire most
of what we've learned about
the brain comes from the kinds of
conditioned behavioral tasks that are
common at premier research
as well in lots of other species and the
very specialized
behaviors um that are sort of classic
neurological models like songbird
learning and
echolocation um and both of these really
are benefited by the fact that animals
repeat the same behavior over and over
at high levels
um which allows you to record neurons
and look at correlations between them
um but each of these sort of brackets at
the end of the behavioral repertoire
really don't represent even everything
that an animal can do and one of the
nice things in modern neurology and then
you'll see
and you know the work that we do and
lots of other people is that
our capacity to be able to quantify and
characterize behaviors
now is such that we don't have to only
rely on these very high frequency
behaviors because we look at behaviors
over long time scales
even ones that occur at low frequencies
um
with respect to marmosets um this has
been a real boon
but also simply because one of the real
key features of marmosets um
where they really excel is in the social
domain so they have a lot of
characteristics and their cognition
communication and social behavior
um that are rare in other non-human
primates but have lots of parallels in
humans and this includes things like
um prosociality imitation they're highly
vocal and so forth
and part of the reason that this is
important is ultimately that
the primate brain is a social brain
right like i always like to say like
it's the only thing that primates do
well we're you know we're we're slow we
can't jump
um we're not very strong our our sensory
systems are pretty mediocre but we're
really good at lying and cheating
and forming alliances and all these
things that um you know really
uh we enjoy watching in television and
movies um
it's because that's what our brain has
changed and it's not that
other animals aren't social they're
social animals in the vertebrate domains
lots of really interesting types of
behavior
but the social landscape of each species
each taxa is very different
so the types of challenges that they
face the way they model that social
landscape and how they would solve those
are all very different and if you want
to understand
how we do this the best case for doing
that is
in species that view and see the world
in the same way that we do and model
that social landscapes
accordingly and this is one area where
marmosets have been really useful
um so my work in the lab kind of brought
broadly touches on three areas um it
doesn't seem like these are all socially
related um but they
are in the long term so part of this is
just building up the basic blocks of how
they function individually
um because the long-term goal is to
really see how they're integrated into
the social
cognitive processes of what this animal
can do so we work on three areas all
motivated by
studies that we do at our field site in
brazil with the natural behavior of the
animals on active vision
where we leverage on the marmoset's
natural hunting behavior um
and their spatial navigation and social
communication
um so i just want to touch on a few of
these and give you some examples for
this
um so marmosets are vociferous hunters
uh they are um constantly eating insects
um so insects account for about 50
of the um the their diet and the natural
habitat um
and what you can see here is it's an
animal that's reaching out and grabbing
a grasshopper out of the grass
um so one of the the areas that were
most interested in terms of vision for
this
are the visual motor integration that's
involved in this um
and also how motion changes right so
each of these are very different from
how these things have been studied
in um not in traditional lab studies
because we're really asking how animals
actively navigate through the world
and what impact this has on their visual
system which is you know very different
than looking at the static stream
um we brought this behavior into the lab
in collaboration austin alex hawk
um and what we've done is we want to be
able to take this behavior in the lab
and
use these great neural network
behavioral track
models like people have cuts here um in
order to better characterize the fine
details
of what the body is doing and what the
visual system is doing so
um what we've done in my lab is build
this simple arena
with multiple cameras where we're
training the network on all these
different camera views
which increases our ability to be able
to track the animal as it moves in
three-dimensional space including
all of its limbs um and all of its eye
positions um so this is exciting
um uh endeavor um and um the next step
here will be recording at different
levels of
the visual system uh separate line of
work um which is focused more on
hippocampus
uh relates to how different ways that
mar
that primates explore and navigate the
world integrates so place cells very
common they've been found in virtually
every mammal that they've been studied
in
so we recently reported that this is a
case of marmosets
um like other primates marmosets also
have
a mechanism for encoding information
in the visual system or encoding spatial
information through visual
encoding so these are spatial v cells or
visual place cells
and one of the things that we see in a
lot of these basic mechanisms is that
what the way that um primates
distinguish between uh exploration and
navigation may be somewhat different so
they seem to be exploring through vision
and then navigating
through by encoding their position
within that that cognitive map
and one of the key things that we're
really interested in is how do these
different streams of information
integrate in primate hippocampus
um so for this we built a 3d arena we're
using different video uh
tracking technology so this is uses
about 20 different cameras
um and part of the reason that it may be
a little bit difficult to see here is
that
using this technology we can not only
measure where the animal is in space but
their gaze direction
um so the the red line here is tracking
the animal's gaze and we can project
that into space
on the next step of this is integrating
a head mounted eye tracking system
which will give us greater resolution on
this
the last um piece of work that we do is
on social communication and we've worked
with
these conversational exchanges and
marmosets um for a number of years
they're socially learned
um during ontogeny they're governed by
rules just like ours and one of the
things that we've
done is to to have an experimental probe
into natural behaviors that we replace
one of these monkeys with software that
behaves like a monkey so we call this a
virtual marmoset
um it allows us to directly engage the
animals in their conversational
exchanges
one of the and this is nice because in a
lot of these sort of um
just natural behavioral tracking you
don't have the experimental
interventions that you might want
so one version of this that we're just
writing up now is that we've developed a
marmoset cocktail party so here
what you have is the animal is trying to
talk to one virtual marmoset that's
that's specifically trying to engage
them in a conversation
and then there are multiple other
virtual monkeys that are ignoring them
and engaged in their own conversational
exchanges and for
doing this we've been able to find is
that the marmosets are using very
similar perceptual mechanisms as humans
as well as adapting their behavioral
strategies to optimize
their communicative advocacy um so just
in some marmosets have really taken off
and
and one of the reasons for this is
because of their amenability to these
natural
behavioral um uh kinds of paradigms
on and that you know marmosets because
of this
have expanded what we can even study in
the primate brain um
and one of the key features that moving
forward that will be a target for all of
this research
is their social behavior cognition and
communication uh and next up will be
uh angie solids thank you
hi my name is angela sales and i'm a
postdoc at dr moss's lab at johns
hopkins university
and today i'm going to talk to you about
bats brains and behavior
the first thing i want to discuss is why
bats bats are auditory specialists that
produce ultrasonic localizations and
listen to their returning echoes
to build a scene of their surroundings
this is what we call echolocation
this active sensing system allows us to
record and analyze the signals that the
bats produce
this means that we can have full insight
into the sensory information that
that guides the bats behavior they are
social animals
that depending on the species can even
roost from a couple of individuals
to several thousand and they use their
voices not only to navigate but also to
communicate with each other
furthermore bats are mammals whose
brains share many similarities with that
of humans
allowing for comparative work and
auditory processing comparative studies
can help separate specializations from
general principles
the bats we work with are the big brown
bats with our which are a north american
insectivorous bed
that produce sound frequencies between
14 and 120 kilohertz
for reference human hearing can only go
up to as high as 20 kilohertz
so you would only be able to hear the
lowest sound frequencies
produced by these bats what i'm showing
you here
is a spectrogram of a spectrum of some
collocation calls produced by this fat
a spectrogram is a way for us to
visualize the cold the bats produce
we can see the sound frequencies that
occur over time
and the color represents the intensity
with the greatest energy
shown in red the foraging bat
controls call parameters and call timing
in response to echo information in the
environment
a traditional capture sequence shown
here involves a search phase with longer
duration costs
then the bat locates the target and the
approach phase begins
here the bat shortens the duration of
the calls and starts emitting them more
frequently
as the bat prepares to capture the brain
they need a fast succession of short
duration calls with lower sound
frequencies
that's called the terminal bus i'm going
to show you now a video of a capture
sequence in the laboratory
where you'll see the bat approach from
the left of your screen and
sweep to the right as it captures the
prey at the bottom of the screen you'll
be able to see the spectrograms of the
calls you'll be hearing
the video has been slowed down for you
to be able to hear these echolocation
calls
[Laughter]
[Applause]
bats are not the only animals that must
track targets
most animals use vision as the primary
sensory modality to track moving targets
this gives them a continuous stream of
information like corey showed you before
the marmoset uses vision
to track the grasshoppers it eats bats
as we mentioned
today use echolocation to build the
scene of their surroundings
that is they use discreet acoustic
snapshots
to track moving targets building
internal models of the trajectory
can allow for the prediction of future
locations of a target and in this way
we improve the performance when tracking
moving targets
in the lab we can exploit this active
sensing system to investigate how
bats track a target moving across their
acoustic field
this is a top view cartoon of our
experimental setup where we have trained
the best to purchase platform
and track a target that is moving from
the left to the right as you can see
here
the bat symmetrical location calls and
aims its head towards the moving target
i'm going to play now a video of what
this looks in real life
this video also has been slowed down for
you to hear the echolocation calls
and you will be seeing the target move
from the right of the screen
to the left and see that accompany the
target with the echolocation calls and
head movements
we have infrared cameras so you can see
the bat but the bat is actually doing
this in the dark so it's relying in
echolocation to track the target
our data shows that the bat is always
aiming its head ahead of the target
motion
we asked ourselves then how is the bet
able to keep ahead of the target
for this we developed mathematical
models to explore different hypotheses
we developed a non-predictive model
where the bat aims its head
based on the last echo return to
estimate target position
as the sound takes time to move across
the air and it only
receives discrete snapshots the
information the bat receives
can be stale and the target may have
already moved from that position
on the other hand we develop a
predictive model which is based on the
bats estimating the velocity
of the target based on sequence of echo
returns
the bat's tracking behavior reliably
aligns with the predictive model
to test this predictive strategy used by
the bats to track moving targets we
added an occluder
to part of the trajectory here as the
target moves across the acoustic field
part of the trajectory is occluded and
the bats can't receive acoustic
information
to know where the target is during this
portion of the trajectory
we found that bats rely on the
predictive strategy to continue to track
the target as it emerges from the
occluder
if it was using a non-predictive
strategy the bat's head would lag behind
the target
the vat's target tracking behavior in
the occluded trials
again reliably aligns with the
predictive model
but targets moving in the environment
are seldomly isolated
usually an auditory scene is composed of
many moving auditory objects and
background noise
the ability of humans and other animals
to sort acoustic signals from different
sources in a dynamic environment is
called the cocktail party effect
as i mentioned at the beginning bats are
social animals and hunting their
lone little cocktail parties where not
only they have to discriminate the
echoes from their own vocalizations
but also attend to communication calls
emitted by roostmates
next you'll see a short video of what
this fat cocktail parties looks like in
the wild
these bats are hunting for insects in
close proximity to each other
and you will be able to hear the calls
through the output of a bat detector
that makes them audible for human
[Applause]
hearing
[Applause]
in these bad hunting cocktail parties
bats are meeting echolocation
and communication calls as you can see
here in these spectrograms
some of the social calls emitted by bats
may resemble a collocation calls and
over a lap in acoustic features
yet they have very different meanings
and the bats are able to discriminate
them
thinking about it in humans a situation
i get all the time when presenting my
work at conferences
is that when people ask me what animal i
work with i say
pat and immediately they look at me
quizzically and say
rat like the bad skulls i showed you
before these two words are similar but
have different meanings
and if you add to the mix and noisy
environment the discrimination is even
harder
we recorded neural activity from the
bat's midbrain and found neurons in the
bad brain
that respond differentially to similar
vocalizations that have different
behavioral relevance
some neurons are selected for social
cause and some are selected for
collocation calls
regardless of their acoustic
similarities this differential
selectivity contributes to the
discrimination
of calls that share acoustic features a
different meaning
working with bats can give us insights
into how different animals track targets
furthering the understanding of predator
prey interactions
and it can advance the understanding of
how the mammalian auditory system works
to track auditory motion
and discriminate sounds in a dynamic
world this is also relevant for humans
especially those who rely on hearing for
navigating their surroundings
or whose hearing is impaired and new
technologies in auditory processing can
improve their way of life
our research program focuses on
investigating natural behaviors
which in turns allows the bats to
exercise and perform natural tasks
such as flying and prey capturing with
that i want to thank the labs especially
my gi doctor cynthia moss
the nsf and our other funding sources
and now we'll hear dr zoe donaldson
speak about social behavior in the
prairie world
thank you thank you so much for the
opportunity to be here today
i'm going to talk to you about my lab's
work which is focused on understanding
the neural basis of adult attachment or
pair bonding
by studying a rodent species i'd like to
begin by thanking the people who
actually carried out this work as well
as the funding sources that made it
possible
and consistent with this panel i want to
start with the question of why
voles and within the context of my lab
the answer to this question is that
voles exhibit behavioral traits
that are not found in other more
commonly studied species such as mice
however they are a laboratory amenable
species and they're evolutionarily close
enough to mice that many of the
technologies
that have been developed to investigate
brain function
transfer well to this species ultimately
i'm interested in
understanding the neuronal basis of pair
bonding or what in humans we might refer
to as falling in love
however there are some limitations to
trying to study the cellular basis of
this behavior in humans
as we can't yet put tiny microscopes
into human brains
and so one of the questions that i get a
lot is why don't i study mice
and the simple answer to this is that
mice don't form pair bonds amongst
mating partnerships
and you can't study something that
doesn't exist and so instead
my laboratory spouse's crow's principle
which states that for such a large
number of problems there will be some
animal of choice
or a few such animals on which it can be
most conveniently studied
and today i'll argue that prairie voles
represent a species on which we can most
parsimoniously study adult attachment
so in the wild a male and a female
prairie will meet
they'll mate they'll establish a
territory share a borough and both
parents will help take care of the
offspring
this is in contrast to the majority of a
million species
where the female will go off and raise
the offspring on her own
and as such these represent an ideal
species for studying
the the biology that underlies social
monogamy
but how do we take something complex
like social monogamy which is ultimately
a social organization system
and turn it into something that we can
quantify within the laboratory setting
my lab and others take advantage of
something called the partner preference
test which ultimately quantifies an
affiliate of preference for a particular
individual
and so what you can see in this video is
that the test animal is placed in the
middle of this three-chambered apparatus
it can then freely explore and the first
interaction that you're going to see is
between this test animal
and a novel opposite sex bolus never
encountered before
and here you can see that this is a
somewhat aggressive encounter
and that's characteristic of prairie
voles who formed a bond
um and they're typically only
affiliative with their partner and so
here you can see this sort of more
positive social interaction they'll
spend the majority of the time
huddling with their tethered partner
this test typically lasts for three
hours and we can quantify the amount of
time that they spend huddled with their
partner
if they formed a bond they'll spend
substantially more time with their
partner when with the stranger
if they haven't formed a bond or if this
test was done with a species that's not
capable of forming bonds you would see
that they don't distinguish between
these two individuals so if you think
about what this test is showing us
ultimately it's that bonds are cemented
over time
by the desire to reunite with an absent
partner
and so with this premise one of the
first questions i asked when i started
my laboratory was whether or not
patterns of neuronal activity and the
nucleus accumbens
reflect partner reunion and pair bonded
voles
we focused on the nucleus accumbens
because of its classic role in
motivation and reward and because it's a
part of the brain where neuromodulatory
signaling is required
in order to form a pair bond within this
species
in order to undertake this work we had
to pioneer the use of envivocalcium
imaging within this species
and in order to do that we actually use
a viral vector
in order to transduce the neurons such
that they glow in the presence of a
calcium signaling event we can then use
a tiny microscope mounted on the
animal's head
to detect these events and so that this
video here is actually showing you what
it looks like when you look through the
microscope
the sort of spider webs are individual
blood vessels within the brain and the
occasional flashes of light that you see
are individual neurons exhibiting
calcium signaling events
the advantage of this approach is that
it enables us to be able to
monitor neuronal activity in freely
behaving animals
such as prairie voles that are
performing a partner preference test
and so this allows us to draw on a rich
literature
regarding the biology of partner
preference using a partner preference
test
so we undertook a longitudinal study in
which animals performed a partner
preference test
initially at day zero where they were
choosing to interact with one
of two unknown individuals they were
then paired with one of those
individuals
mated and then cohabitated with that
individual for the remainder of the
study
we then carried out an identical imaging
session at a short term time point post
meeting
three days after mating and at a long
term time point 14 days after that
each individual time point looks like
this where the behavior is shown on the
left and the neuronal activity is shown
on the right
and so the test animal here is seen as
interacting with the novel it goes over
and starts interacting with its partner
and on the right what you can see is the
video has just been enhanced
to make it easier to see these calcium
signaling events
one of the first things we learned by
looking at the longitudinal within
animal data here
is that prairie voles like humans
exhibit sort of an increase in the
strength of the pair bond given time
and so here they don't distinguish
between the partner or novel individuals
which are both
unknown individuals at the naive time
point but after pairing and meeting
they show a preference to spend more
time with the partner than with the
novel individual
and this preference becomes stronger
over the course of time so we wanted to
ask the question of whether or not we
could identify
cells whose activity might underlie this
desire to be with the partner
and in particular we focused on cells
that might signal
the desire to approach a partner that
you're not currently in contact with so
we identified individual neurons
we identified calcium signaling events
within those neurons and then we simply
asked the question of what does the
animal do after the calcium signaling
event
and we were particularly interested in
neurons that may signal partner approach
as shown here where there's a calcium
signaling event
and then the test animal gets closer to
the tethered animal
now ultimately the assignment of a
neuron to approach neuron or departure
neuron is not based on a single calcium
signaling event but rather the aggregate
aggregate across the test session and so
that's shown here where we can map the
calcium signaling event onto the blue
circle
and then i've shown with the arrows the
trajectory of the animal after
the calcium signaling event such that
for the approach neuron the majority of
the majority of the time calcium
signaling events are followed by an
approach towards the tethered animal for
departure neurons it's away from the
tethered animal
and then for neutral neurons there's no
directional selectivity
using this approach we can identify
approach neurons and departure neurons
independently for the partner tethered
at one side of the apparatus and the
novel animal tethered at the other side
of the apparatus
we then asked the question of whether or
not there were any changes within these
approach cells
as a function of bond formation and
maturation
and what we found is that upon bond
formation and maturation there's
actually an
increase in the proportion of the
population that's signaling partner
approach and a corresponding decrease in
the proportion of the population that's
signaling novel approach and this really
nicely mirrors what we see at the
behavioral level
whereas there's an increase in partner
preference and time spent with the
partner there's also an
increase in the size of the partner
approach ensemble
now this is not only true across the
multiple animals that we looked at but
we can also correlate that with
individual differences in bond strength
so shown on the y-axis here is an
indication of bond
strength and this correlates nicely with
differences in the relative size of the
approach ensemble for the partner and
for the novel individual
so what this means is that we are able
to identify partner approach
ensembles that expand after mating
mirroring the emergence and maturation
of partner preference
that pair bond strength correlates with
partner approach ensemble size
and then in a work that i didn't go into
today we also know that the approach
ensembles are actually specific for the
partner and for the novel vol
and not just approach signaling cells
more generally
and finally we know that the majority of
these approach neurons have signaling
events that precede approach
rather than occurring during ongoing
approach suggesting that they may be
involved in the decision
to approach the partner or novel
individual
so if we sort of zoom out then i think
what we've identified
is a potential neuronal substrate
located within the nucleus accumbens
that may represent
a physical substrate underlying
partner-directed motivation
and my lab is currently using a number
of other tools that have been made
possible through the brain initiative
in order to test functionally test this
hypothesis
and finally i just want to point out
that identifying the neural basis of
selective social motivation
has implications for a wide range of
neurodevelopmental and psychiatric
disorders
that are characterized by either over or
under attachment
and within this category of
over-attachment includes pathological
bereavement or complicated grief
which is gaining more attention as we
face sort of the impacts
of this global pandemic so thank you for
your time
up next is andres medeski who's going to
talk to us about aggression using
siamese fighting fish
i want to thank the organizers for the
invitation to speak in this symposium
focusing on fascinating animals that
nobody else wants to work on in contrast
to the endearing pair-bonding behavior
of balls that zoe just talked about
i will now tell you about animal
fighting and to start i will let david
attenborough tell you why we're using
siamese fighting fish
siamese fighting fish or to give them
their scientific name
better splendens and they come in a
great variety of ravishing
colors so it's not difficult to
understand
why they are very popular aquarium fish
i used to keep them
myself they swim with all the grace of
a virtuoso ballet dancer but but don't
be deceived
watch what happens when i lift this
and they see one another
because the males are so aggressive it's
illegal to put them together in the same
tank
even so each is determined to defend its
territory
they distend their fins and push out
their gill covers
so that they appear larger and more
imposing
if these two males were kept together in
the same tank
they would soon turn on each other and
one of them would almost certainly be
killed
people in thailand have been breeding
betta fish for fighting for the last 300
years
people get together to fight their fish
and the winner of a fight goes on to
breed the next generation
while the loser and his family are
killed thus there has been very strong
selection for aggressive behavior and
fighting ability
because of this strong selection for
hundreds of generations
beta fish have become exquisitely
aggressive
moreover as you saw in the attenborough
video visual stimuli are enough to
trigger and guide
beta aggression providing a unique
opportunity to study the neurobiology
of visually driven aggression today
i'll tell you about the work of two
superb scientists in my lab
clara everett and amy norovic clara and
amy have set up sophisticated behavioral
experiments and clever analysis to
understand
the visual features that control
aggression and the underlying neuronal
circuitry
to start they developed a simple but
powerful assay
two fish are happily swimming in their
own tanks visually isolated from each
other by an
opaque electrochromic screen we then
pass current through the screen
which turns it transparent as you saw
here allowing fish to see each other
here you can see how within seconds fish
start orienting to the fish
on the other tank and mount an
aggressive display
flaring their fins and opening their
opportunity
we video record fish from the side and
from the top
and use machine learning to track
multiple points
in the body allowing us to quantify
their behavior
and their interactions using these track
body parts we then compare the behavior
of fish
before and after the barrier becomes
transparent
we find that fish almost never open
their operculum before they see another
fish
but do so a large fraction of the time
when they see each other
also fish spend most of their time right
next to the wall of the tank
opposed to the other fish and reorient
their heads
towards the other tank
we then use these track body parts to
understand the dynamic nature of
the fish interactions for example what
is one fish doing that induces an
aggressive reaction by the other fish
here you can see three of the possible
configurations that fish adopt
during these pairwise interactions and
we start by quantifying if one of these
is more common than the other
to quantify these postural
configurations we calculate the angle of
one fish
relative to the tip of the head of the
other fish
here on each axis you see the
orientation of each of the fish
interestingly the fish don't adopt
random postures relative to each other
rather there are three main
configurations the fish adopt
the red facing the yellow fish the
yellow facing the red fish
and both facing each other more rarely
fish swim parallel to each other
and essentially never do they swim away
from each other
now we want to understand what fish are
doing when they
open their operculum a classic feature
of aggressive display
we find that fish open the operculum
exclusively
when facing their opponent not when
being faced
now we want to know what fish two is
doing
when fish one opens its operculum
we find that fish erector or perculum
much more
when the other fish is in a lateral
position than when
it is facing it directly suggesting that
this lateral configuration
is more potent at inducing aggression
and now these behavioral analysis of
interacting fish
are useful because they allow us to
measure what animals do in real
interactions
however there is a limit to what we can
understand because we cannot control the
interactions
fish dynamically affect the behavior of
each other
to gain more control over what fish see
claire track the behavior of a fish
interacting aggressively with another
fish and use the software
that pixar uses for their movies to
create an animated movie that precisely
mirrors the real fish
now we can play the same movie to all of
our fish
providing us with a reproducible
stimulus and one that we can carefully
modify to study how different visual
features stimulate aggression
here you can see fish pay close
attention to the screen almost like in a
clockwork orange
for example to measure the contribution
of shape and the statistics of movement
we can compare the aggressive behavior
elicited by a movie of a naturalistic
fish
to that of the exact same fish but now
moving in an unnatural
up and down trajectory we find that
indeed
the whey fish move is an important
inducer of aggression
since the fish moving up and down elicit
much less aggression
now because we play the same 30 second
movie in a loop 40 times
we can determine if specific parts of
the movie elicit more aggression from
the observer than others
on the top you can see a raster of every
time the observer fish
opens its operculum and in the middle is
a histogram of those responses
you can appreciate that some parts of
the movie consistently
evoke more aggression than others
interestingly these parts roughly
correspond to when the animated fish is
in a lateral position
which is consistent with what we observe
in the interactions between the two real
fish
remarkably independent fish are fairly
consistent as to what parts of the movie
elicit
most of their aggression indicating that
these
visual features generalize across
animals
so now that we have a basic
understanding of the psychophysics of
how visual cues
evoke aggression we want to understand
the underlying neuronal circuitry
to start aiming is tracing the neuronal
circuits from the retina
all the way to the muscle that opens the
directs the operculum
since this muscle is almost exclusively
used during aggressive display
so to do that she injected a tracer into
the eye
and found only two parts of the brain
that received direct retinal
input the nucleus rostral lateralis
which is homologous to the lateral
geniculate nucleus and the optic tectum
both in the contralateral side to the
injected eye
then she injected tracer into the
opercular muscle
and found the motor neurons projecting
to the from the trigeminal motor nucleus
so now that we have found the first and
the last relays in this circuit
aim is now identifying the nodes in be
in between
and we know that some of these nodes are
important
because we have performed a brain wide
screen for neurons that are active while
fish show aggression
and found that the dorsal medial tell
encephalic area
which is homologous to the mammalian
amygdala has four times more
active cells when animals are displaying
aggression than when they're observing
an
empty tank so our current work focuses
on developing techniques to measure
neuronal computations of the dorsal
medial talensaphelon
while fish behave in front of controlled
visual stimuli that induce aggression
in this video you can see a fish
swimming with a floating head mount
we will next replace this head mount
with a floating miniature microscope
to optically measure neuronal activity
while fish
are fighting
and with that i want to thank the
whole lot and especially clara and amy
whose work i share with you today
and now we will hear from paul katz
hi it's a pleasure to be here at this
meeting and thank you for letting me
speak about the nudibranch burghest de
vanier
this is a project that i'm going to tell
you about is a collaboration with five
universities and it's funded by a u1
mechanism
from the initiative giant brains evolved
twice on this planet
once in mollusks and and another time
invertebrates
there are many features that have been
conserved between mammals and mollusks
that are listed here and in fact many of
these features have been discovered in
mollusks so
for example the action potential
mechanisms were discovered by hodgkin
huxley working on
squid giant axon and many
neurotransmitters were discovered in
gastropod neurons
however many features also evolved
convergently between animals and loss so
essential pattern generator circuits
which are responsible
for controlling rhythmic locomotion
which i've worked on the last couple of
decades
evolved independently several times
muscular hydrostats in
our tongues and octopus arm is another
example
you'll hear about the next talk also
evolved independently as did
complex eyes olfaction learning memory
circuits and social behaviors
now most also have features that are not
found in mammals and that makes them
worth their being as well
and sorry autonomous arms is an example
of that
so i like to compare bergia which is the
species of nudibranch that we work on
with the octopus
octopus have 170 million neurons in
their brains
this is more neurons than a mouse has in
its brain
bergia on the other hand has only 5 000
neurons so it's it's little brain cousin
this is what the base of the burgula
looks like and if we take a light sheet
image
through the animal using a clarity clear
animal
and light sheet microscopy this is a
picture taken by dez ramirez there's a
postdoc in my lab
you can see the cerebral ganglion
the pedal ganglion which is where the
motor command center is
the rhinophores which are the olfactory
organ at the base of the rhinophobic
rhinophore ganglia
if we take a cross-section between to
the connection
the connective between the rhinophore
ganglion and the cerebral ganglion
we get this image and if we blow that up
this is a
collaboration with jeff lichtman's lab
at harvard and this image was taken by a
postdoc
my lab brandon drescher you see a lot of
axon profiles in this connective
if we blow up this section down here on
the right
you can see that many of these neurons
are tiny these are axon cross sections
notice the scale bar is one micron
many of these axons are less than 50
nanometers in diameter
some of them are quite large and those
are small
we've segmented out this in this image
and we found that there are over
30 000 axons in this piece of tissue
that is only 50 by 70 microns in
diameter
that means that although the brain is
five thousand neurons it's receiving
over thirty thousand
inputs from each rhinophore and then
there are going to be tens or hundreds
of thousands of other inputs to this
very small brain
in some way that's like the octopus
because although the octopus has 170
million neurons in its brain
it has 330 million neurons in its arms
benny hochner at hebrew university in
jerusalem has referred to the octopus as
having embodied intelligence
that is it's not just using its brain to
make decisions
and to make computations but rather
these prop
properties are distributed across its
whole body
bergia also has this property of
embodied intelligence this is a
isolated surat piece of skin with the
serotonin
of these extrusions from the surface
um they without the central nervous
system can make directed movements
towards the forceps
now octopus also have these very complex
eyes in fact this part of the brain is
the optic globe it's a massive part of
the brain and these are axons running
from the eyes
in contrast bergy has this little tiny
eye
and the eye itself is located right on
the brain
brandon has done em images of the eye
and he's found that that you can see the
pigment cup
uh this is the the lens um and then
there's only
five photoreceptors in the eye this
region down here is one of the
rhaptomyric structures that seems to be
the light sensing organ
so this animal only has five
photoreceptors in each eye
yet it can use its eyes to perform
visual navigation
if you put a stripe on the outside of
the container
the rugby will reliably locomote towards
that stripe
and this is work of a grad student in my
lab phoenix quinlan
phoenix also showed that bergia can
perform olfactory navigation in a
teammate they will go towards their prey
item which is a c and m and a
here's a picture of that sea anemone my
other student kate otter has shown that
bergia have to make these approach
avoidance decisions when approaching its
prey because the sea anemone
contains stinging nematicist um that are
toxic and they in these tentacles and
also in these zoconia
bergia eats this anemone um
because it sequesters the pneumaticists
and puts them out in the serrata
as its own chemical defense one way that
it can avoid
getting stung is to act as a group and
so the bergia are
often seen mobbing in anemone i'm going
to skip towards later in this where
they've totally consumed this anemone
so by working together they seem to be
able to
overcome this giant predator and act as
a prey
act how to be their prey now we've seen
i don't know if that's due to social
behavior of the animals or if they're
smelling blood in the water that's
something that we're continuing to work
on
um nonetheless we just saw a talk by zoe
donaldson on on social behavior mammals
and the role that oxytocin and
vasopressin play
this this nine amino acid peptide is
very highly conserved across the animal
kingdom
including gastropods and nutrients
where it's called conopressin like
postdoc cheyenne tate
has shown that in bergia you can use an
antibody that was raised against the
vertebrate version of vasopressin and
stain specific neurons in the brain so
there's a giant neuron in each petal
ganglia
and then there's a cluster of neurons in
the cerebral pleural ganglia
we're currently looking at the behaviors
of social behaviors the reproductive
behaviors that
and the physiological responses that are
controlled by conopressing
now it's no secret that we've known this
for a decade
that many individual neurons can be
identified from animal to animal within
a species based on the neurotransmitter
and the soma position
so this is a common feature of
gastropods in general that they have
individually identifiable neurons this
has been used to study neural circuits
in
in nudibranchs this is the nudibranch
tritonia diumedia
and it was originally started to be
studied in the 1960s by dennis willows
his work and peter gettings and bill
frost and myself
have worked out the circuit diagram
going from sensory neurons
on to a central pattern generator to the
efferent neurons that control the
muscles
and that under this controls the
swimming behavior of this
animal so that these intracellular
microelectrode recordings are showing
the dorsal and ventral summing neurons
that basically are producing the pattern
of activity that
cause this behavior we can
look at these identified neurons in
several species so the same
factors the same anatomy and
neurotransmitter content can be
used to identify a neuron in different
animals within a species can also be
used to identify the same neuron
in different species um
so they these animals have the same
neurons but they do different behaviors
sometimes so
tritone swims with dorsal ventral
flexions dendrinous and melody swim with
left right flexions the neurons are
there but they're wired up differently
and then they have different functions
so we've been studying this for a good
25 years in my lab
um and the limitation is that we're
going
single cell by single cell with
microelectrodes in order to
overcome this obstacle we needed a
species where we can do high throughput
types of behaviors
and in particular we needed one that we
could raise in the lab and that's where
burgu comes in so
bergia lays eggs in the lab and it takes
two months to go from egg to adult and
back again
our colleague on the brain award dd
lyons at ucsd
is using this developmental system to be
able to eject
specific precursor cells the neuroblasts
in the embryo
and have look at lineages of cells in
the adult animal
as well as be able to then in the future
express things like channel rhodopsin or
g or g camp in neurons so that we can
then have genetically encoded sensors
another pi on the grant bill frost from
roslyn franklin university
is using voltage-sensitive dyes to
record from many neurons at the same
time so this is the brain of bergia
this is a photodiode array arranged over
the top of the ganglion and this is
20 minute recordings from over 50
neurons that we were able to do so bill
is going to look at the
activity of neurons during the
production of behavior
so in summary i've shown you that bergia
can be useful for understanding the
other giant brain on the planet
that bergia has amenable features for
studies such as the simpler brain
individually identifiable neurons and
it's easily raised in the lab
and that the bergia brain project is
using high throughput approach to
understand the neural basis of complex
behaviors
so i want to thank the my collaborators
and the other members of my lab
and the next talk is by gallet
and led
okay thank you dr katz for a fantastic
smallest presentation this is the last
species that we will discuss today
and perhaps the most extraordinary of
them all the octopus
i am galit pele at michigan state
university
and my interest in octopus started when
i was an undergrad at the hebrew
university in jerusalem
the first time i entered the octopus lab
there i saw that the octopus swim
happily
towards one of the students but looking
quite unpleased with other students
entered the room and that left quite an
impression on me
the octopus nervous system and behavior
remains mainly
unexplored but giving all of its unique
features
understanding how the octopus nervous
system function
is bound to provide information a new
perspective
on brain function and fuel the
development of new
and innovative technologies recently we
have received funding from the brain
initiative
to study sensory motor functions in
octopuses
the octopus is amazing in so many ways
it has three hearts it has blue blood
it camouflages it has uh
and it regenerates almost every part of
its body
it has no bones and therefore it could
move potentially in an infinite number
of ways
but yet it's performing graceful and
coordinated movement
octopus existed even before dinosaurs
the first for cylinder to be discovered
is from 296 million years ago
so the octopus has a large brain over
500 million neurons
and the arms and the brain together it
has eight axial cords
that acts each one of them like the
vertebrate spinal cord
and here you can see high resolution mri
that we did
and you can see each spinal each axial
cord in each of the arms
it has hundreds of suckers each behave
independently
like a finger and a disembodied arm
exhibit movements that are almost
identical
to movement in an intact octopus and
this suggests that the octopus has
simplified
neural embedded neural programs embedded
in each arm
and it is adaptable to various degrees
of input
from visual and motor areas
understanding decision-making and
goal-oriented movement
is a major goal for neuroscientists
these are the results of course of
complex integration of brain and
peripheral circuits
with its distributed control of the
nervous system
you can appreciate that the octopus
provides an
unparalleled preparation to study
complex
and flexible motor behavior grasping
which is the most desirable movements
the patient
that lost the limb or had a spinal cord
injury would like to have
and developing new brain machine
interface
and neuroprosthesis have allowed to
allow adaptable and flexible grip and
movement
in patients is still a challenge
we are taking a holistic multimodal
approach
to identify the neural circuits that
leads to adaptable
grasping behavior this could be the
foundation
of develop developing prosthesis that
are adaptable
like octopus arms we are asking what are
the neural circuits that leads to
adaptable grasping movement
can we describe them in algorithms and
can we can we reproduce
movement by feeding these algorithms
into soft robotic
prosthesis
we are doing both acute and chronic
electrophysiology recording here you can
see some preliminary data where we
record
potentials from octopus arm
dr chestick is now fabricating miniature
wireless recording devices that will
enable us to record
multi-unit activity in an awake behaving
octopus
so we will be able to identify neural
patterns
that are associated with tactile sensory
stimulations
and also neural patterns associated with
central stimulation and motor
stimulation
of course the recording technologies
that is being engineered in this project
will greatly impact
how can we understand neural circuits in
other aquatic animals
beyond the octopus and probably in other
species
as well
here you can see how one way that we
could measure motion capture with very
high resolution
so using nine reflective markers face
equally
on an octopus arm and detected by four
high resolution cameras
this permit the capture and the analysis
of movements
of three dimension we are able to look
at bend location
bend magnitude velocity strain
axial rotation and the arm and curvature
together we will be able to build the
model
that represent the grasping behavior
another approach in our lab is using
artificial intelligence
to detect motion this will allow
automated and high
throughput motion detection um and we're
using deep lab cut
and we trained algorithm to detect our
movement across
days and weeks of recordings
we are thinking how we can
take tools that were developed in
vertebrates
and use them in octopuses making an
octopus that expresses gcamp and
genetically encoded voltage sensitive
indicators will allow scientists to
visualize neural activity in an
unprecedented way
we are started working on producing
octopus neural cultures
which will be instrumental to establish
these technologies
here you see this beautiful 3d
autofluorescence imaging of octopus
that we worked with emmett imaging
system
these are 25 micron section in four
fluorescent channels
it took 19 hours to image the entire
octopus
so you can see its unique structure the
big brain
even the three hearts
and finally taking care of the octopus
main is the octopus well is not your
average pet and it's pretty high
maintenance
it lives in salt water and it's very
sensitive to its environment
so we bring live rocks that come from
the pacific ocean
which is the our octopus original
habitat
these rocks have the type of algae that
make the bacteria that our octopus
requires and it takes about three months
to mature the water in the tank
to have the right conditions for the
octopus
on top of it the octopus are cannibals
and get very stressed out when they see
another octopus so each of the octopuses
is
housed individually in a 50 gallon tank
the octopus eat only live food and enjoy
it enjoy a diverse diet and in fact each
of our octopus has its own dietary
preferences
we grow different type of crabs
and clams and shrimp
and these species eat algae so now we
have to maintain
an entire ecosystem in the lab and what
you can see here
is an octopus enjoying a snap
i'm quite happy
so at the end i would like to thank the
students
all the students that i presented the
work
and i appreciate nih for supporting my
lab research
that takes advantage of the unique
strength of the diverse species
in this session we showcase the value
of non-traditional species for
neuroscience studies
at the level of circuits and behavior
we presented six different species with
unique features
and unique strength we should continue
to include other species
for comparative purposes and the brain
initiative should support and facilitate
experiments in these and other
specialized animals
broadening the reach and scope of
questions that we can ask about the
brain
and finally thank you for dr karen david
from nih dr cynthia moss from johns
hopkins
who organized this wonderful session
thank you for the speakers
andres bendesky zoe donaldson who
moderates the session
paul cox corey miller angie cells and
myself galit pellet
the brain pi meeting organizer the ninds
communication office
infinity conferences and lab routes and
now we'll have a session for
q a thank you
okay thank you so much to our presenters
and also to karen david and cynthia moss
for organizing this we now have a
session of sort of question and
answer and so i thought i would begin
with some of the bigger questions of
just sort of why
even bother using some of these animals
and to begin with
um sort of pointing out that many of the
core principles of brain
function that have resulted in nobel
prizes in the past as elucidated by
cindy
um range from sort of action potential
generation in the squid to ltp
and eplesia and so we've learned in
organisms
these these were learned in organisms
that would now be deemed non-traditional
and so this first question goes out to
paul and galit
um what are your thoughts on why a for a
formerly more diverse set of organisms
have been largely abandoned in modern
neuroscience despite the obvious
successes of the past
what implications might this have for
future discoveries
i'm having some problems here because
i'm getting the feedback i don't know
how to stop that
um
all right why don't we give you a moment
go eat do you want to do you want to
give this a go
let me see
paul is here but he's having some issues
so we're going to go ahead and uh
we'll let you go first
paul michelle
okay okay so i think that by
um so many
great discovery has been
um um we we we saw
from from the beginning of india's
presentation
many great discoveries have been um done
of course with the aquatic animals
and over the past decades we really
honed only
on a handful of animals and that
probably
we are really missing out on the
diversity of solutions that biology and
evolution
um is providing us so
probably the brain initiative can make a
huge difference
by encouraging work or non-traditional
species
for example by specific our
phase um and
and um it's likely we're likely to
really
um and this is
likely to really facilitate
understanding
of brain mechanisms how other animals
came with
very creative solutions and of course
facilitate the development
of new technologies and is paul there
now
yes i'm here now i forgot what my
sleeping problem was
so i think that the reason that that
a lot of the work is concentrated onto a
small number of animals and
i hope i didn't miss your answer on this
um is that the tools
were having the communities was really
important in developing the tools but
now i think that the tools have gotten
democratized and i think that
we miss important concepts if we don't
look broadly in the animal kingdom
not everything is going to be like a
mouse a zebra fish
a fruit fly and excuse me if i missed
any of the other
c elegans so it's really important to
look widely and to see what the general
questions are what
what is nature found over and over again
in evolution
and looking at convergence is really
important not just homology
great thank you paul so there are
reasons why
a few species have traditionally been
very intensively studied
um and i think part of that goes back to
what we call quinn's law and so i'm
going to ask
sort of angie and corey uh to
to answer this next question but quinn's
law states that the convenience of
genetics
multiplied by the quality of the
behavioral repertoire is a constant for
all animals in other words if you have
animals with
sort of a very charismatic behavioral
repertoire it's likely that their
genetics are going to be more difficult
to access
um and so does this principle do you
think it still stands or have we started
to identify
charismatic behavioral species that sort
of break this rule
answer first
uh sure so you're you're asking if
essentially we're
finding more novel behaviors out in the
world that
warrant further study at a genetic
neural level is that kind of the gist of
the question
specifically genetically tractable or
tractable in whatever sense you want to
study it
right i mean i'm probably slightly
biased right like i i see the
non-genetically
tracked animals as being far more
interesting right i mean
you know mice are the the mice and labs
i mean there are all sorts of really
cool rodents out there right they're
like 40 percent of mammals and
you know thousands of species right so i
mean i think there are
remarkable behaviors that are going on
all over the place
you know i'd far rather listen read
papers on these
sort of weird animals everywhere because
they do these really intriguing kinds of
things that
are just unexpected right i mean like i
think of you know my colleagues that
study frogs every time that i write a
paper with them
and i i say something like oh well no
one does this and they're like well
actually there's this one species found
in the southern
parts of madagascar that you know i
don't know do anything that any organism
has done right so i mean
in many ways mammals have a pretty
limited repertoire of things that they
do i mean they do a few things pretty
well
but you know there's just such a range
of really interesting things out there
that we know very little about
so i think one of the traditional
arguments has been that these species
that do really cool behaviors
are difficult or intractable from an
experimental standpoint they either
can't be brought easily into a
laboratory or
they're they're not easily modified from
a genetic perspective do you think
we're starting to identify sort of an
excellent in between
in certain species where there is
genetic tractability but also these
sort of very interesting and charismatic
behaviors
yeah i mean i i think from my point
right so the the behaviors are really
the motivating force so
whether or not you can turn off every
interneuron in the brain if the behavior
isn't really rich and interesting it
doesn't matter right i mean especially
because of the off-target effects and
what the questions really are
um so yeah i think you know the viral
tools are definitely going to be more
widespread
just by pure
you know capacity and and money involved
in having thousands of lines of
transgenic animals
um and so i think as those viral tools
are expanding it does allow us to dip
into these species that maybe we don't
have the capacity
with everything that's out there and and
mice and
zebra fish and so forth
yeah i just want to add that uh so corey
said like all mamas behave very
similarly
and as somebody who works with that one
that clearly has a very very
specialized behavior um i would have why
are you that
uh but i do think that like tools like
crispr
would allow us to really like dig into
this
specialized behaviors um and really find
out like the commonalities and
differences
between all these mammals and all these
different behaviors that they might be
exhibiting
right i didn't mean to say that you know
that that was overstated for their
they're good at everything i mean i
think you know when i teach my animal
behavior class and you look at all these
non-mammals you're you know you're
always like oh my god like they're all
these things that animals do that are so
amazing
um and then you know it's not the
mammals don't do really incredible
things it's just
sorry yeah all right so there's a
follow-up question from one of our uh
trainees who's been watching the
symposium and so what i'm gonna do is
i'm going to actually call on andres
at sort of one extreme of a species that
was probably relatively easy to move
into the laboratory and delete on the
other end
of probably very very difficult um and
then anyone else who wants to chime in
after they've answered but the question
is
as a trainee working with one of these
non-traditional organisms how do you go
about building background research and
informing your work since there hasn't
been much work on some of these species
how do you balance the fact that other
species might have information about
key differences and how do you convince
grant how do you convince grant
reviewers to care about your species
all right so andre
sure uh i think i would agree with corey
if the behavior i at least for me what's
most important at least initially is
that the behavior is
it's so interesting that then the rest
becomes secondary
obviously if you cannot do any
experiments in love then it it's
intractable but
we don't need to strive to manipulate
every single dendrite of every single
neuron but if we have
something very interesting to study even
and if nobody else has studied it before
we can also go for the low hanging fruit
so
in a sense it actually becomes easier if
you actually get your study
experimental system in the lab and you
can do things then you can
discover even the most essential stuff
because not everybody's working on the
same animal
and and for some of these species there
is some
background there's not like there's zero
at least with siamese fighting fish
they're
installed is from the 1930s on some of
their behavior just observing them
putting them in front of mirrors
but now we can bring them into lab and
use modern technologies to study them in
much more
careful detail so there's in many cases
there is some background that one can
use or from related species from
uh other fish or from other mammals from
what we study so we're usually not
working in a vacuum maybe there isn't
something specifically to our
species but like as you uh we discussed
with the crooks principle
uh like cynthia mentioned in her
introduction we want to study the best
or the species that's most uh
appropriate for a question that we find
particularly fascinating
so i'll let god add to that if she wants
so i think the octopus is fascinating in
so many ways what reviewer doesn't want
to give money
for that i mean we are full of
enthusiasm
so i think everybody should um
it there were quite a lot of challenges
working with the octopus because it's
not
traditional in many labs we they were
they're issues with husbandry
the physiology is not entirely known
what anaesthesia a lot of protocols
there are other questions also how do we
go about neuroethics
associated with octopus so you might
know
that in um europe octa
there um the eu has a
derivative from 2010 that regulates
octopus work
uh similar to what they do in vertebrate
which is not the case in the united
states
it is actually the case in canada so i
think there's also a lot of questions
how we go about
working with these animals which could a
little
slow down the activity and also
how we can use
all the molecular biology and the
genetic tools
that are mainly um
targeted for mice in in rodents how can
we use things like that
in the molars over the last decade
there has been i think a big
interest in using octopus
um the specific type of octopus the
specific species
that we are working with which is the
octopus
uh pima coladas is the only octopus that
its old genome
has been sequenced so that could be a
good start
to go and make a transgenic octopus
gk octopus voltage sensitive
dyson genetic
encoded voltage sensitive sensor
so there are many challenges and there's
a lot to be discovered
but there's just so much to be
discovered
right so i think it's it's absolutely
worth doing
all right so i think within this theme
of sort of addressing challenges i'm
going to go to paul and angie next as
representing two very different species
in which you guys are
have successfully adapted some
neurotechnologies so
so one of the questions we have is what
are the challenges that you've
encountered with adapting some of these
state-of-the-art neurotechnologies
um for new species and what are some
insights that you have gained through
this process on how we can address these
challenges
so okay um i wanted to say that
that we actually it's not right to say
that we're adapting the technologies
that we're using to what we're doing
because in fact many of these
technologies were developed in
gastropods so electrophysiological
processes have been going on since the
1960s
um so this is not new um the thing that
and
what we're we're collaborating with jeff
lichtman and doing the
the connectome and it's actually working
really really well
and part of it is because of the
similarities that we're finding with
octopus of all things
so we have to find communities where
people are
finding similarities and i'm working
towards doing that actually glee and i
are both
partnering and trying to find ways to
facilitate research in most because no
it's not it's not a mammal but it does
have
advantages in many other respects um
one other thing i wanted to point out
with regard to the ground functioning is
i think it's
always important to ask good questions
and important questions
but when you're working on a species
that does not have a large community
among the reviewers it's more incumbent
upon you to even
be stronger in asking the questions the
important questions
and not the little tiny bit detailed
questions that people within a community
might be interested in but not the whole
neuroscience group
yeah as um for the bats like from my
perspective
um there are like some techniques that
we are now
like being able to use for example
the lab is exploring um two-photon
microscopy and some of the challenges
there is that it's a brand new technique
this like has never been done in this
animal and
we have to find the correct viral
vectors that we'll express
in animals that have been for example
vaccinated against rabies
so that's a challenge that you have to
think about
when finding the correct viral vector
and another thing like i'm interested
particularly in
molecular mechanisms and actually
finding
antibodies that will be good to look at
things in the bad brain
has been a challenge because the
genome has only recently been sequenced
and there's like a big project called
the bat
1k that is sequencing the genomes of
different bat species and i think that
will open a lot of doors
to start using some of this molecular
techniques
but it's a very very recent development
corey you wanted to add something yeah i
was just gonna add you know i think one
of the
you know like i always tell people in my
lab you know it's like a double-edged
sword right the benefit of setting
something that no one's ever studied
before is that
your creative capacity like you can do
anything you want and that's really fun
and exciting
the downside is that no one's ever done
anything so you're starting from the
beginning right and so like you screw up
more than you might if there were sort
of tractable questions ahead of you
i mean i think one of the things that's
changed and really in some ways
a little bit of a game changer is that
you know these these sort of
computational modeling
approaches for tracking tracking
behavior like people have cuts and
everything else that lets people hear
using you know like it's this really
beautiful tool that allows you to
replace
years of undergraduates you know like
ticking boxes and so forth right so you
can characterize behaviors a lot more
quickly
once you kind of train your your models
and so i think this allows force
at least on the behavioral side like a
much faster curve to get at a lot of the
things that you're interested in that
even
five years ago wouldn't have been
possible right so i think hopefully that
that
keeps people less being afraid of
jumping into something new
than they might have been when really
you just had to sit there for hours and
hours and days and months and years
watching your animals to figure out how
to characterize those behaviors so
that's a real advantage that's that's
out there for people now
yes i agree and i think also that it
allows us to delve a little bit deeper
because a lot of times we had
undergraduates sitting there counting
say
grid crossings or something like that
there's not much subtlety there
but there's a tremendous amount of
subtlety within behavioral repertoires
um so i also just kind of want to seg
this conversation segue this
conversation a little bit into genetic
tools because that seems to be a
recurring theme that's come up
in particular we have some questions for
people asking about
tools for transduction and so i can
speak to this briefly in the vols so
um i think a general theme at this point
has been that there are at least amongst
aavs many many different stereotypes and
one of the surprising things that we
found in bowls as well as in birds
is that stereotypes that don't
necessarily work well in mice or rats
can work very well in these other
species
and so to some extent there's there's an
element of just test and try
it's going to become more difficult to
the farther away you get from mammals
because a lot of these
aavs have been designed to work in
mammals
in terms of uh transduction for genome
editing i think that that's where we
start really getting into challenges
related to husbandry and the bespoke
nature of reproductive biology
so a good example of this is that yes
indeed we can make transgenic prairie
voles
the first ones that we made we used a
lentivirus to
transduce the genome of these organisms
which works great for a couple of
generations but there's something about
the prairie vole genome
that shuts down virally inserted dna and
so we didn't get any
sort of multi-generational expression
now we can use crispr
to knock out different genes but there
we also had to figure out how do we deal
with a species that doesn't
have an estrous cycle that are induced
ovulators and so it's not just the
technical aspect of like what crispr
constructs should i use
but how do i effectively deploy these in
these species
and so galit i know that you mentioned
um g camp octopi which octopuses which
sounds
super cool can you tell us a little bit
about sort of what genetic tools
do you see as being promising and what
challenges have you faced
so i can tell you for the vols the
funding actually came from nsf
um but glee where is the funding for
transgenic octopuses coming from
so currently there are no transgenic
octopus
the work that has described
the sequencing of the octopus
bimacolatus genome had just came out a
few years ago so this is completely new
we're not we don't have an octopus like
that yet
we are now working on making cell
cultures where we can
try different um
viral constructs and non-viral ways to
transduce the genes we don't have it now
but this is part of our brain initiative
work
so this is part of that mechanism
and my colleague from
dr clifton rexdale so he's a geneticist
with who specializes in
octopus and brain development in octopus
so he's working on that aspect of the
work
let's see um so we've
discussed a bit the genetic tools and
sort of some of the ways that you can
approach transferring those and some of
the information that you need to have
available to do that
but what are some of the other neuro
technologies that your labs are
currently
trying to deploy within these species
and so corey
i'll come to you first you've been
really big on behavior and i think that
that's fantastic
what are some ways that you guys are
exploring some of the neurophysiology of
this
um i mean you know i think there are a
few things right so a lot of it is
you know there are a bunch of different
wireless recording technologies right so
you can use neural loggers you can use
these full streaming
wireless systems they all have their
pros and cons to this
a lot of the work is sort of trying to
integrate multiple measures of behavior
online with um the neural recording
technologies and so this is sort of
you know splicing together multiple
threads um and
you know those technologies are out
there for everyone to use as long as
your animal is kind of big enough to
carry whatever the weight is for the
system
um i think the the the real challenge is
how do you integrate the specific
behavioral recordings that you're doing
with that
in real time in a way that is tractable
right so
that that i think you know for us you
know it's tracking
gays position and and eye location and
that's
that's sort of a non-trivial task for a
monkey that's freely moving and jumping
around you know the neural recording
part is kind of
easy now um but so for i think for us
it's
making sure we're able to get the right
things that we want out of the animal's
behavior and quantifying them
um and then adapting that into a
behavioral recording or a neural
recording system um with
you know a closed-loop system in
principle to be able to also
um interrogate the brain simultaneously
with various you know optogenetic
type tools um so that's sort of the next
step there
and cindy even though you just you did
our opening today i know that you
actually have a long history of trying
to work with some of these uh
some of these neurological tools and
bats even before the brain initiative
was really sort of pushing the uh
the envelope in terms of species
diversity can you speak to
how you got that funded and also sort of
what some of the challenges you faced in
any advice you would have
for people in the field now now as
corey was describing the need to
integrate
many different measures of behavior
along with the neural recordings that's
been a big challenge that we've tackled
but
made some considerable progress so we
combine
microphone array recordings of
ultrasound
high speed video um and in different
tasks and neural recording so this
requires an integration
of the uh wireless uh recordings
and time synchronized with the other
measures
and originally some of this work was
actually funded by a crcns
grant um many years ago and um
you know we continue to seek funding for
it
for this kind of work and
you know it's taken a lot of effort
because a lot of even
working with such small animals requires
very lightweight devices
and because they use high frequency
sounds we have to use
custom audio devices and then the high
speed video so it's been
a lot of technical challenges that now
these days i think many people are
comfortable with but when i first
started
many years ago um with the high-speed
video
we were using a camera system that was
mounted to like a hot dog cart you know
enormous thing
and we had to use reel to reel tape
recorders and so now
with the the digital technology advances
things work much more smoothly
great thanks so much so um we have a
question that was posted about sort of
the translational applicability of
animal models noting some of the past
failures to translate um and i think
part of this is an
assumption that all organisms are going
to be the same despite the fact that we
know from evolution
that species have evolved very specific
abilities in order to thrive in their
specific environments whether that's a
social environment
or an actual ecological environment and
so paul
i know that you had sort of a note about
how much should we expect of translation
i think it's important to recognize that
there is no translation if you don't
have basic research
you have to make the basic findings
before you can translate them to humans
and nobody knows what we're going to
find in basic research if we already
knew that we would have it
so many key findings that are that are
now
commonplace crispr crispr was found
because people were studying viruses and
and
and and um not because they were
studying humans uh
child rhodopsin again bacterial uh
photosensitive
um protein uh micro rna was found in
in cl again so these are features that
you need the basic research for before
you can even think of applying them to
humans
so it's not a matter of of one taking
away from the other
it's that these work together
all right and so we're gonna wrap up
here and what i'm gonna do is ask
everybody just for a quick one line what
is your favorite thing
that we've learned on a basic science
perspective um
from your species or multiple species of
interest and so i'll start off um
paul mentioned this in his talk but i am
absolutely enamored with how much we've
learned about the highly conserved role
of social neuropeptides
specifically oxytocin and vaporpressin
from studying it at a very basic level
and now beginning to understand how it
may affect human social behavior
um so corey you're next um
i guess you know a lot of the things
that i think i've been most excited
about that we've learned with the
marmosets is that a lot of the
sort of assumptions about how the
primate brain work using more
traditional approaches haven't really
panned out to be predictive of what
the brain does in the natural states as
the animals are really navigating social
circumstances
really almost anything we've tried so
i'm excited to see as we continue kind
of pulling those threads
you know how our view of how the primate
brain
really works changes as we go
hey andy
um yeah well there's so many things i
can say about
the wonders of baths and what we've
learned from them um
i guess one thing that um i'm very very
interesting
interested in is how they are able to
like discriminate
sounds that are like overlapping and
really like
making sense of this cocktail parties
and we've learned a lot about
um the auditory system in studying this
but also like things like 3d spatial
navigation and 3d
scene representation um which are really
novel because
you can't really study this in other
species if you think about
place cells in mice and rats it's all in
a two-dimensional plane but when you
study it in baths now
you're suddenly like in a
three-dimensional space which is like
really really interesting thank you
andres you're up next sure
uh maybe i shouldn't find this
surprising but i still do every time i
work with animals in the lobbies how how
they can maintain
so much of their natural behaviors of
even in the control laboratory
conditions we keep them in we
i mean we try to make it as
ethologically relevant as possible but
that they will still
fight and that they will communicate
that they do so many of their things in
this very pristine control conditions
that
it works as a to an advantage for us
that we can study them carefully but i
find it surprising how
how much they still behave naturally
let's say
great and paul you're up next i think
it's really important and
and striking that you have to understand
the animals umvelt this is the
ethological phrase about the environment
that the animal experiences not the
environment that we think that they're
experiencing because they're
they're not us they are different and we
can learn from those differences
and that's what i think is most striking
perfect i think that paul put it much
better than i did
all right and go eat you want to round
us out
just a couple of specific things about
octopuses
the brain is somewhat different than
ours
in its organization it doesn't have the
somatotopic organization the mammalian
brain has
and yet my the octopus in my lab
they enjoy playing with legos they
seek um to they are so
playful and they are so creative and
they
initiate play so maybe what we consider
in our brains right how
things work are not the only way that
they can work
and their evolution came with so many
creative ways
to make just amazing um
amazing behaviors and our octopus has a
favorite
a favorite arm to use even though all
the arms are exactly the same so their
biology is just amazing and we have to
keep exploring
that's fantastic and cindy can you sort
of sum it all up for us with one final
thought and i think then we'll go ahead
and close
you're muted cindy
sorry about that we've heard some
fascinating um examples of animal
um that can really provide important
insights to neuroscience that
they can really answer some of the
bigger questions
and we need to forge ahead and continue
with this line of
comparative research
thank you so much um so with that i'd
like to thank our speakers as well as
ninds the brain initiative
and also everybody who tuned in today
thank you for your attention